j'enrage à mon uniforme ont pris sans
rien comprendre
j'ai rien senti
g j'ai entendu une détonation ni coup de
feu était l'un des premiers
voilà ce que je t'ai le plus grand et
comme la pluie pour mort il m'a pas
retiré dessus du coup j'ai prises des
mâles et qui a traversé les deux jambes
et l'autre directement coup en fait et
pas contre des camarades ils ont pas eu
cette chance puisque c'est chabé et
malheureusement il a continué at il
assuré
[Musique]
à
à mon réveil j'ai vu de l'ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy qui m'a regardé et m'a dit est
ce que vous savez qui je suis jeune
homme mais avec la morphine je les
regardais dans les yeux et j'ai secoué
la tête et je me suis endormi et une
fois pas mort et veille
j'ai cru que c'était un cauchemar en
fait donc j'ai juste un peu son rôle et
un moment en me disant que ça sera un
cauchemar c'est un rêve que je sens
train d'halluciner et quand j'ai
vraiment vu les yeux je vois mal
d'années devant moi m'a tenu la main
elle m'a dit garder mon sang-froid
d'essayer de me calmer au moment où elle
m'a dit tout ça j'essaie de bouger
j'arrive pas alors je lui dis qu'est-ce
qui se passe selanne a dit monfils
c'est un terroriste quitte à tirer
dessus
un autre banc devant le régiment je me
préoccupe est plus de savoir ce que je
vais pouvoir debout que la respiration
j'ai même pas que la l'époque j'avais le
nez occupée on va dire sectionné j'ai
l'impression de de suffoquer comme
quelqu'un qui qu'ils aient pas nager à
un certain moment je voulais pas vivre
voulez plus vous voulez vraiment pensé
que ça aurait été peut-être mieux que je
ne sois pas là
je me pose des fois même la question
maintenant est ce que je continue comme
ça c'est tout ce que jules et pour
l'instant je m'accroche je m'accroche me
bats chaque joue mais pourtant c'est dur
c'est très dur de voir que chaque jour
quand je me réveille quand je regarde
mon corps qui ne bouge pas c'est
terrible
[Musique]
d'accord journée à l'hôpital
alors mes journées c'est simple il ya
des moments où l'après midi je vais
faire du vélo à l'aide d'une machine aux
cyclosportifs ou sinon je suis plutôt
sur internet puisque alors d'aujourd'hui
la domotique a fait énormément
énormément d'efforts avec mon fauteuil
électrique bas je peux néanmoins les
soumet mais le matin film sortir oui ta
famille est ce que tu viens souvent
alors ma famille sont gentils ils
viennent quand ils peuvent soit tous les
4 mois ou soient tous les trois mois ça
dépend si je respire tout seul je serais
déjà parti mais là depuis que j'aurais
vu ici et depuis que c'est arrivé je les
vois pas souvent mes amis mes meilleurs
amis qui sont là bas et je ne vois pas
imminente
ma famille me manque et c'est difficile
de prendre à sa famille en fait et je me
retrouve aujourd'hui tout seul ici
rêve qu'ils ont c'est faire un projet
dit dans le sens où je peux avoir au
moins un foyer une maison prouver
quelque chose
un endroit où vivre tranquillement parce
que je suis aux invalides mais même et
en titre a tj janvier aussi d'avoir une
maison quelque part mais somptueux chez
moi avant mon intimité
est ce que ça te procure tout ça me
rappelle mois auparavant
même si je ne le suis plus mais je suis
comme un fier de ce que j'étais là où
parle et c'est pour ça je me bats aussi
pour montrer que je suis encore là